I came from a really wonderful career
doing kind of the same thing for a long
time and I knew I was good at it but I
didn't really know the extent to which I
could deliver and you won't really know
until you push yourself and give
yourself the opportunity to fail taking
this year's giving me this opportunity
to really play around with things to
challenge myself to put myself in
positions that would make me
uncomfortable potentially fail to
reevaluate what's important to me both
personally and professionally you know I
keep thinking I get some basics in
accounting and finance and I've walked
away working with some friends on
billion investment funds and I was the
one that ran the financial modeling for
it so just these opportunities to like
really grow and challenge myself the
classes have given us the framework for
that
that's probably the most important thing
with my classmates we've been able to
really push each other to take those
risks and do the things we want to do
but we're scared to do and so I would
say that they have held me the standards
I didn't realize I could be held to
taking risks is really what shows you
how much you can do I have failed
sometimes in little ways sometimes in
huge ways and the sense of resiliency
I've gotten from that is something I'll
take with me
through every aspect of my life through
my career my personal life in the years
ago
[Music]
you
[Music]